[Musik]
russland ist ein rätsel innerhalb eines
geheimnisses umgeben von einem mysterium
das hat schon winston churchill
festgestellt und ich freue mich heute
über einen gast der seit jahren auf
dieser spur diese großen landes ist und
damit auch auf der spur wladimir putins
herzlich willkommen udo lielischkies ja
hallo herr liche sind sie sind
langjähriger korrespondent in moskau
gewesen sie sind verheiratet mit einer
russin sie haben eine große russische
familie die auch in russland nach wie
vor lebt wie beurteilen sie die aktuelle
lage was hören sie von ihren kontakten
von ihren freunden dort also gottseidank
ist meine familie recht entsetzt über
diesen krieg und sagen dass auch wo sie
ungern am telefon darüber sprechen das
tut man in diesen tagen nicht so gerne
aber ich weiß dass mein schwiegervater
man sagte mir wenn das gar nicht gut und
aus einem anderen kreis rund um die
familie hörte ich schäme mich an russe
zu sein also da ist offenbar das
bewusstsein da erzählt aber andere
familien von denen ich jetzt höre wo
innerhalb der familie sogar zwei lager
vertreten sind wo ein teil voll hinter
putins krieg steht in der ukraine und
der andere eben nicht und das ist eine
echte zerreißprobe
der neunte mai liegt diese woche hinter
uns da ist er mit viel sorge erwartet
worden manche menschen haben auch wir
geradezu mit angst auf diesen tag
geblickt das ist der tag an dem
traditionell der sieg über den
nationalsozialisten gefeiert wird mit
großen paraden vor allen dingen auch in
moskau
und wieder haben befürchtet dass putin
eine generalmobilmachung ankündigen
könnte das ist kurz noch mal reinschauen
da wird auch noch einen kleinen eindruck
bekommen was er da gesagt hat
die vorbereitungen für eine weitere
operation im dollars und eine invasion
in unserer historischen gebiete
einschließlich der krim wann offen im
gange
kiew kündigte den ermöglichen erwerb von
atomwaffen an der nato block begann mit
der aktiven militärischen erschließung
der an unser land angrenzenden gebiete
auf diese weise wurde systematisch eine
für uns völlig inakzeptable bedrohung
geschaffen und 2 an unseren grenzen
alles deutet darauf hin dass ein
zusammenstoß mit dem neonazis den bann
lehrer anhängern auf die die usa und
ihre jüngeren mitstreiter gesetzt hatten
und vermeintlich sein würde
wir haben es gehört putin hat den spiess
also wieder mal umgedreht er hat nichts
von dem gesagt was befürchtet worden war
hat sich zurückgehalten
drastische drohungen blieben aus die
flugshow blieb aus wie bewerten sie das
war das vielleicht auch wieder kühlen
schwer zu sagen also die rede wird in
der tat als eher defensiv wahrgenommen
er hat noch einmal dieses fürchterliche
fand bild dargestellt um zu
rechtfertigen warum wir diesen krieg
begonnen hat der kein krieg ist bis
jetzt erst zurückgeschreckt vor weiteren
schritten kriegserklärung und general
mobil machen weil auch viele sagen das
könnte ganz schön gefährlich werden für
ihn das heißt ja das wird sich die
polizei auf der straße wer fähige leute
unter umständen einsammeln würde damit
würde der krieg sehr hautnah in familien
reinkommen und vielleicht hat er da
zweifel ob das aber sich das leisten
können im augenblick sie haben ja viele
jahre beobachtet zu beginn ihrer zeit in
moskau war ja noch gar nicht so lange an
der macht was würden sie sagen wenn sie
auf ihn schauen wie er sich verändert
hat im laufe dieser jahre als er war zu
beginn der eher unsichere blässliche
schwer wahrnehmbare putin der dann in
den kreml gehievt wurde von jelzin mit
der seltsamen tricks und er hat dann
aber die macht sehr schnell erstmal
stabilisiert und dann begonnen sie auch
aufzusaugen und wie wir alle wissen
macht korrumpiert und totale macht
korrumpiert total und das ist glaube ich
der prozess den wir jetzt beobachten
können er ist jetzt in einem
elfenbeinturm angekommen umgeben von
ganz wenigen hardlinern kritische
stimmen kommen gar nicht mit zu ihm wie
man sie sagt und auf merkt weil er die
lage völlig falsch eingeschätzt hat er
hat sich zu einem bösen zaren entwickelt
er offenbar jetzt auch noch versucht
eine historische tat zu vollbringen
nämlich diese schreiende ungerechtigkeit
wie es empfindet den zerfall des
sowjetimperiums
durch die usa bewirkt das wieder
zurückzudrehen und sich zu rächen für
diese schmach die er so empfunden hat
schon damit wir schauen auch zurück in
deutschland gerade auf das jahr 2001 da
hatte eine rede im bundestag gehalten
er hat auf deutsch gesagt der kalte
krieg ist vorbei und es hat damals
wahnsinnig viel hoffnung gegeben die
sich mit diesem besuch verbunden haben
heute fragen wir uns fast wie konnten
wir so dumm sein ihm zu glauben
medienfragen heute hat er uns damals
eingelullt wie würden sie das bewerten
es kann sogar sein dass er glaubte ein
nettes verhältnis zum besten erstmal
haben zu können parallel aber seinen
kleptokraten
staat aufbauen zu können es gab auch
eine große sehnsucht bei uns im westen
dass dieser kalte krieg und die ganzen
damit verbundenen spannung endlich mal
vorbei sein würden das gab das standing
ovations aber natürlich putin hat
angedeutet er wolle weiterhin einen
demokratischen russische staat bauen das
war natürlich quatsch sagt selbst
alexander rahr ein biograf und wohl in
der ära putin
auftritt der sagte der westen hat nicht
verstanden dass putin und seiner clique
nur darum ging den zugriff die macht zu
behalten und den zugriff auf die
russischen rohstoffe und mitnichten
darum eine demokratie aufzubauen
auch sie haben ja geschrieben dass er
damals einen sachlichen und ruhigen
eindruck auf sie gemacht hat
wie denken sie heute darüber denken sie
darüber nach wie es dazu kam
haben sie das gefühl sie hätten
vielleicht auf ihn anders schauen können
oder was beschäftigt sie das in
irgendeiner form na klar ich hatte einen
klugen studioleiter thomas roth und wir
haben in den tagen nach dem jetzt hinter
gut in den kreml beförderte viel
diskutiert und ich muss zugeben ich
sagte nein vielleicht ist ja gar nicht
so schlecht das ist ein nicht dauernd
betrunkener rechten nüchterner und
konzentrierter technokrat der könnte dem
land ja ganz gut tun thomas dort ich
lieber damals schon sagte
udo damit kommt der kgb zurück in den
kreml und das ist schrecklich und jetzt
gibt's gerade neues buch von kathrin
welten das netz kann ich nur empfehlen
wo diese ganzen seilschaften gezeigt
werden die sich rund um putin schon
damals gebildet hatten und die er immer
weiter gesponnen hat und leider hat
thomas recht behalten und heute haben
wir da einen fürchterlichen fast von
totalitären polizeistaat ja und das
bedeutet nichts gutes für die meisten
russischen menschen und ich filme für
mich sie selbst haben ja auch ein buch
geschrieben mit dem titel im schatten
des kreml indem sie vor allen dingen
sich jetzt auf die reise begeben haben
in russland vielen menschen sehr nahe
gekommen sind
wie können sie sich erklären dass so
viele menschen in einem so großen land
diesen putin folgen offenbar folgen wir
kriegen ja wenig mit spekulieren das
sind gerüchte natürlich
was würden sie sagen ist der grund dafür
oder wie schätzen sie das ein nachdem
sie so viele russinnen und russen ja
kennengelernt haben putin hat etwas sehr
klug erkannt er fing an erst mal relativ
zivil und baute seine macht vertikale
demontierte demokratische strukturen und
leute waren zufrieden damit zum einen
weil demokratie ohnehin kein so toller
wert für sie bei einen 90er jahren das
war für die meisten russen er eine
chaotische zeit haben ersparnisse
verloren da haben sich theologen das
vermögen zusammengerafft also das klingt
nicht so gut und es ging ihnen besser
und das liegt daran dass putin das glück
hat dass unter seiner herrschaft der
ölpreis immer weiter anstieg beim
geldziehen waren es 25 dollar pro barrel
unter putin ging es dann hoch acht jahre
bis auf 140 dollar das geht nur nicht
ewig gut wie wir wissen jeder ölstaat
hat irgendwie das problem dass die
preise darunter gehen das passierte 28
und da begann die unzufriedenheit und da
musste sich etwas neues ausdenken und
seine zweite erzählung sein zweites
narrativ das war der aggressive westen
wir uns wieder an die wäsche will uns
die rohstoffe in sibirien wegnehmen mit
uns angreifen wir müssen jetzt
zusammenhalten und der trick war
natürlich in so eine art kriegssituation
bedroht und bedrängt vom westen da ist
kritik an der regierung verpönt dann
sind hier fünfte kolonne aktion
vaterlandsverräter also jetzt klappe
halten nicht kritisieren und durchhalten
offen die lage schwierig ist und er hat
immer weiter dieses negativ des zweiten
weltkriegs aus den schubladen geholt und
das land militarisiert und man kämpft
dann schon seit vielen jahren wieder
gegen nazis an jeder ecke und das hatte
ich immer weiterentwickelt und ich kann
mir eine schöne geschichte erzählt putin
hat immer wieder gesagt russland muss
wieder ein stolzes land werden die
russische welt ist nicht die schlechtere
für dich mit der westlichen etwas
unterentwickelt und weniger intelligente
sondern das ist die bessere welt und ich
bin mein dorf gefahren bei sotschis wir
sind viele milliarden hingeflossen
direkt nebenan 7 bergdörfer alle ohne
straßenverbindung selbst das geld und
die löcher zu zu machen war nicht mehr
da die wurden versorgt und eine
schmalspur eisenbahn des ehemaligen
holzbetrieb ist damit wurde das brot
hochgefahren und die kinder und im
letzten dorf nach drei stunden rumpel
fahrt sehr gefährlich komme ich in einem
dörfchen namens anna galon nie und geht
an den in den laden der auch brot
bekommt aus dem teil und drei
verkäuferinnen stehen darum ich frage
sie wählt dann geht der nächsten wahl
putin natürlich und das dorf war
fürchterlich kaputt die hälfte der
häuser zerfallen autowracks überall
schweine laufen über die schlammige
dorfstraße und gruselig einer hat mad
max für russ des ostens und da sagen wir
diese damen doch die akkus hat auch
unser land wieder von den knien erhoben
zu einer stolzen nationen gemacht das
war so ein irrer widerspruch ja diese
beiden damen in diesem absoluten chaos
aber die vision wir sind wieder ein
stolzes land und das ist sagte mit dem
fernsehen das ist die propaganda die so
toll wirkt weil sie rund um die uhr auf
allen kanälen das gleiche erzählen ist
das heißt wir sprechen dem buch auch von
dem ewigen kampf der russen zwischen
fernsehen und kühlschrank das ist damit
gemeint sind damit genau der kühlschrank
steht für die realen lebensverhältnisse
und das fernsehen für diese propaganda
maschine die inzwischen so teuflisch
ausgearbeitet ist dies heim ethisch
inzwischen ja und das klappt immer krim
aktion dann ging uns war fernsehen wir
haben das ding zurückgeholt das gehört
uns ja sowieso die krim die werte gingen
durch die decke aber das bröselte wald
irgendwann die leute in den kühlschrank
gruppen doch ist heute immer noch drin
ja und so schön diese diese vision des
des stolzen russland auch ist aber wenn
ich da und hunger haben es ist doch
nicht so witzig und dann brauchte er
neues und haben damals schon überlegt
was macht er denn als nächstes um diesen
patriotischen funken wieder zu erzeugen
der ihn an der macht hält er braucht das
denn sonst kann ehrlich erklären warum
die menschen so schlecht alle ex
republiken der sowjetunion leben besser
inzwischen deutlich besser und haben
keine öl und gasvorräte wie das reiche
russland und das muss ja irgendwie
erklären worum gehts euch so schlecht
obwohl wir doch so reich sind
wir stehen hier auch jeden abend in den
nachrichten wenn wir sehen o töne auf
den straßen moskaus
natürlich gibt es die weniger aus dem
dörflichen gemeinschaften und die
menschen sind wirklich mehrheitlich
hinter putin glauben sie dass da eher
die angst mit eine rolle spielt zu sagen
dass man ihn vielleicht doch nicht ganz
unkritisch sieht oder denken sie dass es
irgendwie doch mehrheitlich auch da
unterstützung gipfel ihn es ist wirklich
schwierig denn die menschen haben viel
viel angst und umfragen wäre noch
telefonisch gemacht und möchte am
telefon dann dokumentierbar sagen das
hat die politik oder den krieg ganz
schlecht findet dass das wurde ja schon
für gefängnis reich wenn er das wort
krieg ausbricht es kommt vieles zusammen
es ist teilweise ist diese propaganda
auch eine art brücke eine ein
hilfsmittel für die menschen um nichts
tun zu müssen die menschen sind verwirrt
viele haben natürlich gehört dass es
andere informationen gibt ein blutiger
kriege wir schlachten der ukraine und
dann gibt es die die staatliche
propaganda wir befreien sie von nazis
und das gibt im kopf irgendwann mal so
eine komische situation dass die leute
verunsichert sind dann klingt
entnazifizierung erst mal ganz gut und
wenn man sich darauf einlässt dann muss
man ja auch nichts tun denn es müsste
man ja auf die straße geht man müsste ja
was riskieren und da ist die propaganda
auch so ein hilfsmittel um sich selbst
quasi eine kleine chance zu geben still
zu halten
das zweite ist das lese ich auch mal
wieder natürlich dieses gefühl ukraine
sind eben menschen zweiter klasse das
ist so ein bisschen wie unsere
ostfriesen soll ich aus friesland
ukraine wurden oft aus moskau
perspektive sehr herabwürdigend rach lee
genannt sind so unkultivierte bauern und
und aber das ist ja nicht umgegangen die
machen wir ab und zu mal lese genau aber
in der ukraine ist es noch böser und das
jetzt ganz tief putsch gegen hat böse
dinge über die ukraine geschrieben
brodsky also auch in der russischen
literatur es ist ein altes narrativ dass
die koreaner sind so einen turm
bauernvolk und jetzt haben sie sich dann
auch eingebildet sagen die die soldaten
die einkommen das sind der soldaten das
entfernen ost nord sibirien aus diesen
unfassbare heruntergekommenen ländlichen
gebieten russland auf einmal sehen dass
diese verachteten bauern aber ein
fernseher haben einen computer haben und
richtig nett leben das hat glaube ich
sehr verwundert
also spielen viele dinge eine rolle auch
die verrohung natürlich in russland ist
wird er oft gefragt die können
russischen soldaten denn so brutal und
grausam sein gerade heute gab es wieder
ein video wo zwei soldaten fragen bitten
ruppiner und eine zigarette kritisiere
die gehen weg und die verschießen die
von hinten
vor laufender kamera also das ist auch
ein phänomen das natürlich gewalt eine
riesenrolle spielt in der russischen
gesellschaft es wird gefoltert alle
enden auf polizeirevieren in
gefängnissen sei das dokumentiert die
zahl der der frauen die durch häusliche
gewalt sterben ist hundertmal höher als
bei uns dass ein tausende pro jahr ja es
ist schon auch ein sehr gewalttätiges
rechtlos klima aus dem diese jungen
soldaten jetzt kommen die denn gar keine
moskau oder petersburger soldatenmütter
kämpfen so sie merken schon ich könnte
ihnen die sendung füllen das ist ein
buntes spektrum von von verschiedenen
motiven auf welche gruppen kann es denn
überhaupt von westlicher seite aus
gesehen noch eine hoffnung geben es
wurde es gab hoffnung oft vielleicht die
überzeugungskraft der oligarchen auch da
gibt es übrigens gerüchte dass in der
letzten zeit sehr viele von dem
gestorben sein sollen was auch immer
daran ist werden wir nicht erfahren es
gibt aber auch die hoffnung auf die den
verein der soldatenmütter der ja
offenbar eine große wirkkraft haben soll
in russland das heißt das sind die
mütter die angst haben um ihre söhne die
im kriege eben offenbar ja auch
inzwischen zu tausenden gefallen sind
wie schätzen sie das ein und das heißt
die hoffnung stirbt zuletzt aber viel
habe ich gerade nicht ehrlich gesagt was
eine bevölkerung angeht dass da so eine
art aufstand entsteht das ist schwer
vorstellbar weil auch der
repressionsapparat ist er sehr dicht und
der deckel auf den topf geschraubt
sozusagen
und die garten- oder wohlhabendere leute
mittelstand gehobener mittelstand die
sind überwiegend sauer auf das was putin
macht es gab keinen tollen artikel von
jewgeni albers eine polizistin die hat
viele bekanntschaften in dem quasi um
alle anonym gesprochen die haben sich in
parks getroffen auf einer parkbank ganz
ganz diskret aber da ist die stimmung
ganz klar die sagen himmel was macht er
da denn nimmt und dieser gruppe
natürlich die möglichkeiten geld zu
klauen und ins ausland zu schaffen
das ist ja fast nicht mehr möglich dass
das finde ich ganz schrecklich es könnte
allenfalls also wenn sie doch etwas
hoffnungsvolles hören wollen wenn es aus
dem kreise der silowiki der
geheimdienstler militärs die nimmt man
gewalttaten gewalt ministerium dass aus
diesen kreisen immer mehr gäbe die jetzt
allmählich begreifen was da passiert und
dass ihr leben sich gerade zu rückwärts
entwickelt richtung neunzigerjahre
richtung richtung mangelwirtschaft dann
wäre zu hoffen dass da vielleicht was
entsteht aber nochmal das ist ein sehr
lange aufgebautes system der repression
und wie viele mutige menschen haben sie
die es wagen unter einsatz ihres lebens
zum zweifel gegen einen solchen
autokraten diktatoren wie man sie dann
wohl vorzugehen nun ist es ja so dass
offenbar nicht nur die russische
bevölkerung zu großen teilen des
informiert ist sondern man hat ja auch
fast den eindruck dass putin selber dies
informiert war zumindest hat er offenbar
die kraft der russischen armee
überschätzt und die kraft der
ukrainischen armee unterschätzt wie kann
denn sowas passieren eigentlich nicht
denn er hat ja einen gigantischen
geheimdienstapparat das ist ein volk da
spricht dieselbe sprache also es werde
nun ein leichtes gewesen
herauszubekommen dass die eben nicht mit
blumensträußen auf die russen und ihre
panzer warten sondern dass die im
gegenteil auf keinen fall und der
russische gute kommen wollen das zeit
genau dass putin kriegt nur noch die
analysen die ja auch gerne hören möchte
es gibt keine menschen offenbar die es
wagen ihm auch mal eine andere wahrheit
zu vermitteln es gab einen noch den
letzten mohikaner der hieß alexej kudrin
das war ein ehemaliger finanzminister
ein liberaler denkender mann der hatte
noch zugang zu putin was auch weniger
hatte in der endphase aber das ist auch
vorbei seit krämer lektion gute halbe
himmels willen macht das nicht das
wollte putin damit höheren er hat es
gemacht nachdem das gut und auch
abgeschoben und jetzt bleiben wir noch
ein paar falten um ihn rum und wir haben
so aus dem inneren von geheimdiensten
gab es jetzt briefe ob echt oder nicht
wissen wir nicht ganz genau die auch das
beschreiben dass die da oben gutachten
bestellen aber ein bisschen putin
ankommen sind die schon sodann
modifiziert dass sie in sein gewünschtes
weltbild passen ja das ist zum beispiel
für den absolut abgekapselten
alleinherrscher
offenbar absolut unterschätzt hat er ja
auch die nato den zusammenhalt in der
nato den zusammenhalt des westens und
auch die bereitschaft mit waffen zu
unterstützen natürlich die ukraine
jetzt ist es klar dass finnland
beitreten möchte auch die schweden
werden vermutlich der nato beitreten
russland hat ja eine sehr sehr lange
grenze mit finnland und er hat jetzt der
seinen angriff schon damit begründet
dass ihm die nato zu nahe gerückt ist
und wollte ja das unterschreiben wir
unterschrieben wird dass die nato eben
nicht mehr an russland ran rückkehr hat
jetzt das gegenteil erreicht nämlich
eine grenze die über 1000 kilometer lang
ist direkt an seiner russischen seite
oder an der russischen grenze linie
fürchten sie dass er sich dadurch jetzt
erneut provoziert fühlt und weitergeht
das tut er auf jeden fall aber ganz kurz
zurück zum unterschätzen der westlichen
geschlossenheit das muss man noch mal
ganz klar sagen das haben wir uns selber
eingebrockt
nennen wir das letzte die annexion der
krim entfesselt einen krieg in der ost
ukraine
ganz klar das hat wurde immer geleugnet
dass es da soldaten gab und waffen
gehabt aber das war natürlich quatsch
das war sehr schnell klar als modernste
russische waffen und soldaten werden ein
witz damals ein bisschen zynisch da hieß
wenn es aussieht wie ein pferd wenn das
vieh hat wäre wenn es galoppiert wind
fährt ist das wahrscheinlich ein pferd
und wenn das pferd dann sagt ich bin
kein pferd dann ist es garantiert ein
russisches pferd das war so eine story
die wir uns damals erzählten weil es war
so unfassbar der widerspruch zwischen
den hunderten von beweisen die es gab
und der leugnung aus moskau und ich habe
mich auch programm beschwerden bekommen
ohne ende und habe mehr programm
beschwerden beantwortet als beiträge
gemacht das hat sich natürlich sehr
wütend gemacht so aber was ich sagen
will nach der annexion der krim nach
diesem krieg am donnerstag klar von
moskau initiiert war haben wir uns ein
bisschen empört in brüssel und berlin
haben auch ein paar flammen weichen
sanktionen beschlossen und nur knappes
jahr später hat sigmar gabriel himself
mit kräftiger unterstützung von gerhard
schröder und großer duldung von angela
merkel haben wie putin sein größtes
denkbar nach geschenk präsentiert
nämlich nord stream 2 wurde da
eingefädelt stellen sie mit solchen mit
solchen schritten hat der westen oder
haben wir wie immer sie es nennen wollen
ganz klar ermutigt natürlich musste da
nicht erwarten dass wir auf die
barrikaden gehen natürlich kannte er den
westen immer nur als jemand der der
protestiert die backen aufblasen
nichtstun nach abchasien nach
südossetien nach der grimme lektion wie
sollte er den ahnen können dass auf
einmal der westen hier haltung einnimmt
und und hielt die usa gerade 40
milliarden beschlossen das ist schon ein
größerer da ist man nicht hinterher
immer schlauer helle licht auf die
korrespondenten haben damals durchaus
positiv berichtet natürlich hat die welt
darauf geschaut und hat gesagt ach ja
und jetzt gibt's hier gas keiner wollte
wahrscheinlich wollte man in der tat auf
die krim nicht schauen weil es nach
vorne weil es weiter gehen sollte ist
das ein riesen land also müssen wir uns
da nicht alle fragen
was wir da eigentlich übersehen haben
ich weiß nicht welche korrespondenten
sie meine bei alle die ich moskau erlebt
habe ob sie nun deutsche waren
französische britische
skandinavische wer auch immer hat tut
ihn uns sein sein system sehr sehr
präzise und kritisch beschrieben ich
habe über den tschetschenienkrieg
berichtet und diese unfassbaren
kriegsverbrechen in tschetschenien diese
wahnsinnige grausamkeit das war vor der
bundestagsrede da haben wir bei alle die
augen zugemacht nicht via
korrespondenten sondern politiker weil
sie so sehr wollten dass das endlich mal
ein nettes verhältnis wird da hat keiner
gesprochen über diesen brutalen
tschetschenienkrieg da ging es ja schon
los und wir wussten auch die pute an die
macht kam da mussten ja wasser
explodieren damit das funktioniert denn
längere geschichte ja aber eigentlich
jemand der offene augen hatte und ein
buch lesen konnte oder in einem
fernsehfilm man etwas längerem hinsehen
konnte der wusste natürlich was da los
ist wir wollten das aber nicht will wir
wollten auch geschäfte machen der besten
es hand ist opportunistisch und auch
korrupt lagern das sind es bitte
trotzdem noch mal kurz zu fehlern
zurückkommen weil die frage sich einfach
stellt ob das jetzt noch mal eine neue
dimension ist in der wahrgenommenen
wahrgenommenen bedrohungen seiner
grenzen sie merke ich drücke mich immer
gerne zum zukunft geht weil das ist
natürlich auch schwierig mit diesem
herrn da was zu prognostizieren
natürlich ist das eine gewaltige
provokation natürlich ist die finnische
grenze ihm sehr nahe ja das ist ja noch
mal quasi in seinem archiv gefährlicher
als der wegfall der ukraine als
pufferstaat weil es hätte ja keine nato
truppen oder keine nato mitgliedschaft
der ukraine gegeben so schnell was er
macht weist man nicht es gibt szenarien
klar ich kann hier gut leben denn es
gibt immer wieder angst ums leeren tanks
ja man denkt er könnte seine taktische
bombe zünden die zum beispiel stockholm
oder helsinki als stadt nicht vernichtet
also nicht die menschen tötet aber ich
weiß was ich das heißt einen puls
auslöst und damit sämtliche
vernetzungen internet jeder fernseher
jeder toaster jedes telefon alles ist
kaputt sie müsste nicht ganz neu
verkabeln das könnte man sich vorstellen
als eine ja unterhalb der ganz großen
hiroshima schwelle drohgebärde aber
natürlich würde das auch reaktionen
auslösen in washington die wir alle noch
nicht so einschätzen können
das sind furchtbare spekulation und
aber dass er sich provoziert wird klar
aber er hat es ja selber ausgelöst ist
ja das verrückte das ist was selbst
vorfeld kräftig was da passiert das ist
noch aufs inland gucken in deutschland
hier ist ein ja würde mal sagen
wettstreite intellektuellen dem
briefeschreiben entbrannt die reine
gruppe hat sich ein kanzler scholz
gewendet und hat gesagt wir keine
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine wir
befürchten den dritten weltkrieg die
andere gruppe kam einige tage später und
wollte genau das gegenteil nämlich dass
noch mehr waffen geliefert werden wie
ist ihre haltung in dieser frage zweite
gruppe zweiter gruppe aus welchem grund
das heißt das ganz einfach da ist ein
land mit 40 millionen menschen ohne
nachvollziehbaren grund mit mit dem
vorgetäuschten gründen angegriffen
worden um es nicht nur sich
einzuverleiben sondern um es auch als
land als identität als kultur völlig zu
zerstören
und wenn der westen da nicht hilft und
das ist abgesichert durch durch un
regelung ist alles ist völlig klar dann
wüsste ich nicht wo wir überhaupt noch
einmal irgendwo helfen sollen dann
sollten wir uns sofort in unserem
kramerladen zu ziehen und sagen das ist
völlig wurscht was was ihr völkerrecht
nicht passiert auf der welt hauptsache
wir machen einen guten deal da muss man
aber auch so sagen dann sind wir bereit
mit jedem schlechter jeden deal zu
machen das hat ja nicht tun da sind wir
einer meinung ja dabei wissen was ich
meine ist man jetzt nicht zugespitzt
aber das ist ein so eindeutiger fall
da gibt es auch wenig grauzonen was die
kriegs begründung und was die motive
angeht weil sie ja so deutlich dargelegt
worden sind wenn man diesen 40 millionen
kleiner jetzt nicht zur hilfe kommt und
das kann man auch nur mit waffen das
geht nicht mit guten worten das
lächerliche ist ja in diesem brief eben
von schwarzer und wären daher logisch
war und wir immer da unterschrieben hat
dass man immer wieder verhandlungen von
man so mit putin verhandeln aber das ist
doch absurd wie soll das denn aussehen
gute bildung nicht verhandelt es sei
denn man sagt du hast du in der bitte
schön da gehört ja alles und das war
keine verhandlung und drittens müsste
man auch die ukraine habe fragen ist ja
deren land wir können denen ja nicht
oktroyieren das dass sie jetzt
gefälligst irland aufgeben und sich
unterwerfen lassen und damit wir am
besten schnellsten zählt damit russland
das in zwei geschäfte machen können sie
haben eben schon zwei angesprochen
leider ist es ja so dass wir natürlich
die nächsten jahre auch wenn wir jetzt
da sehr sehr zügig vorgehen als auch von
deutscher seite abhängig bleiben werden
vor allen dingen vom russischen gas nun
merken einige leute auf nicht nur einige
sondern glaube ich sogar viele weil die
ukraine nun kriegsbedingt schon teile
der gaslieferungen nach deutschland
gestoppt hat halten sie das für ein
bedrohliches erstes anzeichen oder ist
das eher zu vernachlässigen in ihren
augen bin ich ehrlich ich kann nicht
beurteilen aber es stimmt was die
ukraine sagt nämlich dass es
kriegsbedingte technische gründe gibt
für dieses abschalten unterstelle ich
mal kannst ihnen aber nicht beantworten
was wäre sonst das kalkül der ukraine
uns quasi ohne
zwingenden grund gas vorzuenthalten uns
ihrem partner der jetzt langsam langsam
aber doch vielleicht ein paar schwerer
waffen liefert ist mir nicht so
plausibel entgeht mir da auch was ich
habe nichts gehört was darauf dafür
spreche
dass die ukraine das tut ohne die
genannten gründe eben beschädigungen was
immer das ist sie leben ja inzwischen
mit ihrer russischen frau in deutschland
auch ihre kinder die ja größtenteils
also bislang in moskau aufgewachsen sind
wenn man selbst in der zeitlichen
relation sid mit welchen gefühlen
schauen sich für ihre familie dann in
die zukunft die namen deutschen pass an
russischen pass
sie haben mit gemischten natürlich im
vorfeld zwei kinder jetzt nach moskau in
den sommerferien ich bleibe hier
auch was ist einfach keine gute
situation ist für jemanden der doch
recht deutlich immer wieder 60 äußert
spricht über schätze ich mich auch
vielleicht gibt es da keinen grund
befürchtungen zu haben vielleicht einen
kleinen jedenfalls wurde mir abgeraten
so muss mal kurz zu machen und ja ich
mache mir große sorgen weil russland
wird sich ökonomisch zurückentwickeln
jetzt auf eine eine phase wie in den
neunzigern ist werden fürchterliche
lebensbedingungen siemens hat heute
angekündigt sich zurückzuziehen als wie
eine weitere firma es wird bald keine
hochgeschwindigkeitszüge merck geben
autos werden bald immer teurer jetzt
schon 40 prozent und bald immer weniger
flug der flugverkehr wird immer weniger
werden das wird alles in sich zusammen
bröseln und das wird ein ganz
schreckliches leben dort ja und das
macht natürlich riesige sorgen weil wer
weiß wo man natürlich erleben wollen
finden die dort deutschland oder europa
spannender oder russland am ende doch
julian ist in amerika groß geworden
sechs jahre also meine ältere tochter
ich weiß nicht wo die enden aber diese
wahlmöglichkeit wird jetzt gerade ein
bisschen eingetrübt weil das leben in
russland also es recht unter einem
solchen regime wie wir es jetzt dort
haben aber selbst wenn das mal anders
würde wird auf lange lange zeit
beeinträchtigt sein vor allem ökonomisch
natürlich was glauben sie wie sich das
deutschlandbild der russen und das
wandbild der deutschen in den nächsten
jahren verändern wird
also bei den russen ist zu befürchten
dass viele sanktionen jetzt verhängt
werden die jetzt auch immer spürbarer
werden natürlich nicht als logische
folge von putins fehlverhalten
interpretiert werden sondern als eine
weiter bösartigkeit des westens noch
einmal dieser propaganda apparat ist so
perfekt und thermischen zwischen dass
man den ja auch erzählen können sich
erde ist eine scheibe es ist wirklich so
da ist nicht mehr viel an an chancen als
ähnlich wie wahrheiten zu hören also
wird man natürlich sagen der westen seht
ihr was putin immer gesagt hat sie
wollen uns fertigmachen und jetzt haben
wir keine autos mehr und keine produkte
mehr und das und das funktioniert ich
mir klar das wird erst mal dass das
vorhaben seien trügen was waren jedoch
wissen wie die deutschen aus russland
kommen
deutschland sind eine homogene sind dann
sehr heterogen ist folgte gerade selber
an moderiert sie wissen da gibt es ein
großes spektrum und war das delikt hier
diskutieren war in selbst ein bisschen
ja das würde ich gerne aber wir sind am
ende der sendung danke ihnen für die
wertvolle einblicke vielen dank udo
lielischkies
[Musik]